Speaker 1: All right, everybody. I
hate that I have to do this video,
but after more than two weeks, I don't have a
choice anymore because our YouTube channel is,
quite frankly, on the verge of death. You know, I
know that haters joke about David. You're circling
the drain and all of this stuff. Quite frankly,
as far as the YouTube channel is concerned,
things look absolutely terrible right now.
I was hoping that this would resolve and
that I wouldn't even come to you with this as a
big, strong guy. Right. But it's getting worse.
Something has happened and our videos are no
longer being recommended to viewers in the way
that for years and years they were. Now, you will
notice there are no conspiracy theories here or
irresponsible speculation. It's me telling you
the facts and the numbers and then giving the
most charitable hypothesis about what happened.
We have 1.6 million subscribers on YouTube,
and there are now videos that are
sometimes getting 2000 views. Now,
I know my haters will say, David, that's because
your videos suck. Well, some of them may suck.
Okay. I won't. I won't deny that. But as a sheer
mathematical reality with 1.6 million subscribers,
our videos would never get 2000 views. Even a bad
video was 15,000. 20,000 views. Here's the story.
On January 9th, mysteriously, there was
a roughly 6 to 7 hour period during which
are a live analytics showed almost no views like
not a few views, but just almost zero. And we're
putting that up on the screen as little as like
1900 views in an entire hour during a time of day
where we'd normally have 100,000 views in an
hour or even more. This impacted our channel
and others. Our channel was not the only one
impacted by this. Some of our colleagues in left
wing politics were impacted by this, and people
outside of politics were impacted by this fine.
YouTube told us your views are fine. This is just
a reporting glitch. So it's just sort of like, you
know, if smoke detector goes off, it might go off
because there's smoke, but it might go off because
the smoke detector is broken, malfunctioning. We
were told the views are fine, but the next day
things were supposedly fixed. After three or four
days, some slightly higher numbers were replaced
in our analytics for that six, seven hour period
on January 9th. But I could immediately tell that
views were dead, subscribers were flat. One day we
even lost subscribers. After gaining subscribers
every day for years, we actually lost three
subscribers net one day, and since January 9th,
the channel has been dead. There are videos
that after 90 minutes, after 2 hours, have
2000 or fewer views. We're putting that up on the
screen for you to take a look at. Again, this is
something that just hasn't happened in years. And
you do the math with 1.6 million subscribers. It
just doesn't pass the sniff test. Views revenue
are down 60 or 70%. Subscribers are at a crawl.
Now, this is happening to many channels of people
that, you know, I'm not going to mention them.
It's not appropriate if they choose to talk about
what's going on, that's absolutely fine for them
to do. However, it is not affecting all of our
channels. There are some creators in news and
politics whose channels are doing absolutely fine
now. I genuinely have no idea what is happening,
but I have some speculations. Okay. I am not
claiming at this time that anybody at YouTube did
anything malicious. I am not claiming at this time
that YouTube made a decision, Let's screw over
David Pakman and a bunch of these other creators.
I don't have the evidence to say that, so that is
not my hypothesis at this point in time. Something
took us completely out of the recommendation
algorithm. I even noticed it when browsing
YouTube on my personal account not connected
to The David Pakman Show channel. I used to get my
own videos recommended. They are completely gone.
Here is one of dozens and dozens of emails from
viewers explaining this. Tom wrote in and said
I exclusively scroll through the recently uploaded
YouTube category, but other categories are likely
populated by similar algorithmic logic. I noticed
a month or two ago I stopped seeing your videos
recommended. I had to manually search for your
channel to find it. This also happened with some
of my other favorite creators. All of those in
your channel have one thing in common. I started
to ignore those videos on YouTube because
I watched them on other platforms Patreon,
etc.. Since then I've noticed that whatever
channel I click on in recently uploaded has
a. Massive impact on what is recommended in the
future. Dozens of emails like that. I'm going to
give you the most innocent explanation. Okay. The
most innocent explanation is there was this glitch
on January 9th and it hurt us during that six hour
period, but then caused something to happen which
led to no engagement. Maybe it was a period during
which our videos didn't come up as recommended for
people anymore. Whatever it was, it became
a vicious cycle and it told YouTube no one's
clicking David's videos, so stop recommending them
altogether. That's not me saying someone did it. I
don't know. But it is what happened. So right
now we have to see if we can fix this. I need
you to help me with super simple tasks that costs
nothing. Okay. We need to try to re-engineer our
way into the algorithm. If this doesn't work,
it will be a really good piece of data about
what might be going on. Now, if it works, that's
absolutely fantastic. So here's what I would ask
you to do. I believe if a few thousand people do
this, it may fix the problem first. Do a search
for David Pakman on YouTube and click on one of
our videos. Do it a second time. Do it a third
time. The key is search for David Pakman. Click on
the videos, which will train the algorithm. This
is what people are looking for when you click onto
my videos. Please make sure you are subscribed.
Please, please, please. And make sure after
subscribing that you click the bell and select
all. This tells YouTube Not only am I subscribed,
I want to see David's videos in my feed.
Please like the video and if you can please leave
a comment. Now ideally, if YouTube then shows you
more of my videos and the recommendations either
to the side or below the video you're watching,
click another one of my videos. Ideally like it
comment. The idea is string back to back videos
of mine together, which is hopefully training the
YouTube algorithm. This is the this is the path
people are actually looking for. Now, if you
don't get any recommendations for my videos,
if you only get Jimmy Fallon and Jimmy Kimmel
and other people named Jimmy. Search for me
again. Click like comment. Now, if this entire
thing is nothing nefarious and we simply fell
out of the algorithm, just several hundred or
ideally a couple of thousand of you out of the
1.6 million subscribers and some non-subscribers
doing this, this might fix the problem completely
and resolve it. If it doesn't, then it'll
be really useful information and whatever's
going on is even worse than we thought. Now, the
other part, YouTube revenue is down 60 to 70%.
We count on that. We're counting on using that
money to launch the Spanish channel. We are very
close to launching a dubbed to Spanish version of
our channel to hit the Spanish speaking community.
Dubbing is really, really expensive. Really,
really expensive. Thousands of dollars per
month. We were counting on the revenue from the
main channel to fund the dubbing on the Spanish
channel. So this is a very bad time for this to
be happening. Please grab a membership at Join
Pack. McConnell Okay, it's really cheap. You can
use the coupon code 24 starts now. You'll get a
sizable discount pay full price or not, whatever.
We just need to supplement. 60 to 70% is a big,
big, big, big deal. So let's do it. Let's give
this 48 hours and then I will report back to you
whether this did anything at all, anything at
all to deal with this algorithmic issue that we
are experiencing. And if it doesn't, then it will
give us more information and we can go from there.